and just say y'all folks we're live okay
good we are live episode 131 with liz
wheeler and if you don't know liz
wheeler she likes to keep it safe she's
not controversial at all you don't push
buttons you like a safe space type of an
environment so folks if you're listening
today you may get upset you may feel
safe you may feel all of it but we're
happy to have you on the podcast today
thank you i brought some emotional
support you know animals ponies unicorns
we saw the outside yeah and our guys are
taking care of it just so you know
perfect perfect we bought a purifier
just yesterday not for you because
potentially we have a guest
that may participate in some
extracurricular activities so we just
decided to bring it in just in case not
me no no not you but he is looking at
you though yeah but meaning you're
willing to support in case that does
take place i want to everyone to feel
included inclusion so i don't want you
to feel alienated your level of
generosity is at a whole different level
and sarcasm yeah but we're on it today
so liz is here yeah so for people who
don't know
your story you're all over the place you
know your show your podcast
uh uh i think it was a political 30
under 30 on what you were doing the
voice you have you got a lot of people a
lot of followers a lot of fans why don't
you share your story with the audience
that doesn't know your background yeah
thanks so much for having me by the way
you guys are killing it here um
especially i just watched your episode
with rod blagojevich man i love that guy
what did you think about him so he's so
good i mean obviously a corrupt crooked
politician right yeah so likable so
you did a really good job asking
questions too
uh and letting him tell the stories man
it was entertaining i thought you did a
really good job um yes i am very excited
i host the liz wheeler show we are
almost one year into this independent
venture which i am just having the time
of my life building this my background
is actually cable news i hosted a show a
prime time show on one american news for
five years before i decided to take the
leap into independent media for a
variety of reasons
the biggest reason because the average
age of the cable news viewer is over 65
years old and that's an average age
average age yeah so just old people are
watching the cable total boomer yeah
which i love i love all my boomer fans
but we all agree yeah yeah but they
agreed
with me that that you know the biggest
voting demographic in our country is
millennials and soon going to be gen z
these people need to be
talked to need to be talked with
um and you are a millennial i am a
millennial yeah i'm 32 i'm 32. um a lady
typically doesn't reveal her age but you
know when you're when you're looking 30
under 30 it made me like sad for a
minute and then i felt like i should be
honest and talk about what my 28.
i could claim it but you know i don't
know if it's believable um yeah so we've
been i've been hosting this show it's
really great it's been a ton of fun i've
been traveling around to college
campuses talking to
kids on college campuses who are so
interested in what's happening and
interested in discerning the truth
um i wrote a book a couple years ago on
how to engage with leftists with
basically how to how to defeat them it's
called how to topple the left house of
cards um my viewpoints have actually
changed just a little bit not on
political policy since then but at the
time that i wrote that it was published
in 2017 i thought okay people need to
learn how to actually engage it's such
an intimidating thing right to
talk to liberal friends or liberal
family or people at your college
and not know what to say not have the
exact response for a specific talking
point from the left and i thought well i
work in this business i know all of the
answers to that let me write a handbook
or a manual so that people can learn how
to do that too
and it's not that i reject that
viewpoint now i've just realized that
given the ideology that is so pervasive
on the left right now this this very
marxist ideology whether it's critical
race theory whether it's the transgender
ideology um 1619 project this this
anti-american attitude coming from the
left that we actually can't always
change people's minds call this cynicism
that's come with age but we can't
necessarily change people's minds but
what we can do is we can enact policies
that stop the creation of new leftists
meaning stop people from being
indoctrinated into marxism and so that's
that has resonated in a such an
interesting way with young people on
college campuses to hear like oh i might
not be able to change this this crazy
professor's viewpoint but i can actually
do things at the state or local level
that stop his viewpoint being taught to
children or stop his viewpoint being
applied to me so that's what i've been
uh spending the last semester doing
talking to college college students
about about that and you know just
diving into this this new media that
we're all doing what what what are you
hearing when you go talk to college
students what do you like and i'm not
talking about people that agree with you
because people who agree with you it is
what it is there's no converting theirs
people that
don't agree with you that are open to
receiving what are you noticing with
them yeah i mean they immediately appeal
to
kindness and compassion or how they
define kindness and compassion so one of
the most common questions that i get
from
leftists is oh i have a transgender
friend or i have a transgender classmate
and i don't want to deny their dignity i
don't want to deny their personhood i
don't want to anger them by not calling
them by the pronouns that they choose or
not acknowledging what they're suffering
and that's a very valid i mean that's a
very is that the most common response
that it has to do with trans
pronunciation of their
how they identify that's the most common
thing you hear literally the most common
thing that i hear from college age
liberals is you are not being kind to
transgender i am just trying to be kind
to these people because these people i
mean the narrative is that they're
bullied the narrative is that they
commit suicide at very high rates which
is true on both accounts um and these
college kids want to know you know why i
don't support
their transition
because they these students believe that
the transition is actually being helpful
to the students you have 100
conversations how many times does the
trans stuff come up with these people as
the first thing they bring up a lot
really like 50 80 that's insane that's
crazy because yeah it's like a heavy
topic right yeah
i guess but
less than one percent of the world is
identifies as traumatic go back and
think when you and i were in high school
that was a long time ago right 24 years
ago we were 25 years ago we were in high
school there was no cell phones right
for me 25 years for you 23 years there
was no cell phones there was no social
media there was no facebook there was
none of that stuff so that's what
they're seeing every day so they're
seeing those videos going viral that's
the topic they're seeing the controversy
chapel stuff they're on the caitlyn
jenners of the world you're not nice
you're not you know you're too
disrespectful yet people be why don't
you accept and that's
that's the conversation they're probably
going through there's a difference
between like what's being seen and the
reality that that gets so such a
non-issue for 99.9 percent of americans
but you got the world the campus the
campuses well it's it's a good part of
human nature though to want to be a
voice for the voiceless or to want to
stand up for the marginalized so i don't
discourage that i just i encourage the
the college students to actually define
well what is compassion what does it
mean to actually help these people what
does it mean to give them dignity and
respect because we should treat everyone
with dignity and respect and fight for
equality under the law but it's not
compassionate to push them into a
surgery that they're going to regret
that's irrevocable it's not
compassionate to indulge delusion that's
that's not compassion that's actually
the opposite that's that's a form of
abuse you have trans friends yeah you do
and how do you have those conversations
with them my trans friends tend to be
conservative
conservative trans friends yeah
yeah they give an example give an
example of one chad felix green
chad felix green and what's the
conversation with him or to you know
chad being transgender what's
his uh approach towards politics versus
others he's very much against the
transgender ideology as it as it
pertains to our current political topic
he understands that he suffers from
gender dysphoria that's a real thing
it's a mental health issue he
understands that he suffers from that
and that it causes him to want to
mutilate his body and he resists that he
know he understands that you know he was
guided a lot by walt heyer i don't know
if you're familiar with walt heyer walt
heyer is probably 65 70 years old right
now transition was born biologically
male transitioned to a woman spent 20
years as a quote unquote woman and then
detransitioned because of regret and now
helps young people who are suffering
from gender dysphoria either
detransition or
cope how you should with the mental
health issue so chad still identifies as
i mean he says he's transgender he says
he suffers from gender dysphoria but he
doesn't he didn't undergo surgery yeah i
think the the biggest thing is the fact
that you can't have the conversation you
can't challenge you can't push
somebody's
uh uh you know whatever argument they
may be having that's the issue but but
it's great to see somebody like you i
think
you're doing it charlie's doing it few
people are doing it that are going on
campuses and it's creating a ruckus i
mean it's getting what have you had an
experience where they wanted to kick you
off campus has that happened to you yet
or no um are they pretty friendly to you
well no they're not friendly to me so
what typically happens or what happened
i'm trying to think of what college this
was i think it was at the university of
michigan we went to the university of
michigan late last fall and you know
they put posters up the yaf students
young america's foundation students that
host me on the campuses put posters up
for the events all over and they they
plastered probably a thousand of them
all over the walls just to make a show
and then they caught on video leftists
who are ripping them down one by one and
throwing them in the trash can
um there's been a really interesting
change though on college campuses five
years ago if you went to a college
campus and talked about a controversial
issue a lot of people would turn out who
didn't agree with you
it was in fact i mean you've everyone's
seen those video clips where the leftist
just getting squashed by some um owned
if you will by some conservative speaker
and they wanted to engage they thought
like listen my arguments will get the
best of you they wanted to have that
engagement
um
they don't they don't come anymore they
don't come any more the same way i mean
since since the advent of cancel culture
since the advent of these safe spaces
and trigger warnings and everything they
typically just go outside and protest
and they don't want you to be allowed to
be there versus engagement
so you're saying they're trying to
cancel you they don't even want you on
campus versus coming and debating you
and engaging you and having and i always
invite them i actually i actually always
stay before i go anybody who disagrees
with me my producers will bring you to
the front of the line at the question
and answer like i want to engage are you
speaking at a podium are you just going
out and and no no these are
the ones
no no it's not man on the street it's an
event a hosted event where you know
hundreds of people come and it's in an
auditorium generally um just like a lot
of other speakers i mean it's a it's a
very common thing that happens in
college campuses different clubs bring
in different speakers
yeah but but i love that though i love
anything having to do with debate i love
it i love your courage to go out and
have those conversations we need
way more people who have the courage
like you to go out there and talk people
especially
opposition to talk to these younger kids
go ahead tom you know what's really
interesting is is
my wife the biz doc babe she teaches 7th
8th grade and kids are coming in with
the notion that to disagree remember
there's disgust process and then open
conflict now open conflict is
disrespectful yelling back and forth but
processing the kids don't feel that
processing is polite or nice well that
wouldn't be nice that wouldn't be polite
so you've got kids there in the
formative years sixth seventh eighth
going into middle school about to be
teenagers for the emotions kick in and
they are sort of being indoctrinated by
a system that says don't process because
that wouldn't be nice and that elevates
to in high school well you don't have
the right to question someone else i'm
not questioning i just want to process
something that's of social importance or
something i think maybe we can both
learn from suddenly you go from nice to
right to cancel and that's the flow
exactly what you just brought up pat and
it's happening i think that's the worst
part of it because what we're seeing is
the downstream issue downstream issue
pollution happens upstream downstream
the lake is polluted and we look at it
and go gosh how do we fix this the
upstream problem is these kids won't
aren't even being taught how to have a
civil processing discussion let me let
me let me ask you guys a question here's
a question for you so i go to uh
maestros i'm having dinner there with
jen and it's her birthday and i our
waiter comes i'm talking to the waiter
so tell me uh where are you from he says
well i
grew up in san diego but i lived in san
francisco and now i'm over here i saw
fantastic i said how do you like it in
florida she says yeah it is what it is
just where are you from i said i lived
in l.a 20 some years i lived in dallas
for five years and i've been in florida
for one year how do you like florida i
said i love it what do you love about
florida
i said policies
freedom let me do what i want to do low
taxes no taxes low regulation lifestyle
etc etc i like that also about texas but
it wasn't the lifestyle he says okay
walks away then he comes back
and i said let me ask you a crazy
question here says yes yes and he's now
he's quick with me
i said is it fair to say that you lean
more left than you do right
yes i do
i said how do you handle it with your
family we have one rule that we follow
what's that
we don't talk politics
just we just don't talk politics that's
how we keep our families together so so
here's a q but you got to realize we've
heard this for the longest time you
don't talk politics you don't talk
religion you don't talk this when you're
doing business or with your family isn't
that a way of copping out and not
willing to have the tough conversation
that you need to have what are your
thoughts yeah for sure i mean those
should actually be the conversations
that you
that happen first and foremost around
the family dinner table i mean that's
that's the actual real safe space is is
for parents to talk about these issues
with their children for children to be
able to ask questions and not think
about the ramifications that might
happen in the classroom or with their
friends but to ask their parents the
awkward questions that they might have i
mean this is this is something of course
that's lost i mean this goes back to the
whole deeper issue of the nuclear family
right because parents should be
indoctrinating their children they
should be passing on their values their
principles their religious views their
politics to their children and then when
their children are adults then you can
say okay do i want to continue as an
adult in following these these values
that i was taught but yeah i mean
students students in school in college
it's actually shocking sometimes
what they don't know because they
haven't heard anything except for what
tom was saying that speech is violence
if the speech offends someone well liz
if if trans is the number one issue that
they bring up what's number two three
four
oh what what do you care about the youth
the gen z my youngest sister is uh 19
she's in college so she's right at that
age she is right at that age yeah they
care i mean they care about they don't
care about fiscal issues because they
don't they don't have any money they're
not working
yet
it's really interesting too if you think
about it the government just gave you
two trillion dollars in checks it's
going to happen somehow you don't have
to worry about it is it climate change
is it they're very fearful of climate
change one thing i think is interesting
to note though is we are setting up
their generation for this incredible
financial failure not even because of
all the spending which is obvious but
because of how we're teaching them
fiscal irresponsibility with college so
we send them off to college and these
colleges cost 20 30 40 50 000 a year
they come out at 22 years old with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt
and yet then we tell them don't don't
spend what you don't have live live
within your means and this is just
completely opposite of how we've
culturally forced them to go to these
institutions in order to be successful
but i'm sorry go ahead oh let me talk
about the climate change thing for a
second there are a significant number of
genziers who actually suffer clinical
anxiety and insomnia they have sleep
problems because they're worried about
climate change because they believe the
folks that say oh the earth is going to
be 12 years yeah the 11 the aoc 11 years
and the earth is totally gone well when
you hear that and you're only 18 years
old and for your entire life you're
thinking you're going to be dead in 10
years wouldn't you also have the same
nerve-wracking situation going on if
you're 17 18 19 years old and that's all
you've ever known if it's all i've ever
known sure but i mean that goes back to
i mean that's why pat does what he does
that's why i do what i do because there
needs to be a counter narrative of
reality these kids want to hear the
truth that's the thing they want to hear
what's real they are hungry for facts
they are hungry for knowledge they've
just only been fed one side of it which
is why you know my independent venture
pat's independent venture are very
successful because people actually do
really really want to hear um the facts
of what's going on so i mean there
shouldn't be a 17 year old or an 18 year
old or a 19 year old in our country
who's only heard that the earth is going
to end in 11 years and that they
shouldn't have children and that we
should ban airplanes and red meat they
should say oh i hear that from one side
the other side says this now let me
think for myself you know well whenever
i watch tom i talk to his kids he's
always talking issues with his kids
always talking he'd read this article
read that article what do you think
about this what do you think about that
they're always going back and forth
right and they'll send the notes to him
and he'll show it to me look what bailey
just said look what brooke just said
look how she processed this right
remember when we had rfk on uh first
time around when we kennedy i asked some
questions i
tell me about some of the kennedy
traditions what are some of the kennedy
traditions that you guys have he says
every night at the dinner table
our father he would start a debate
he would say what do you think about
drugs why are they bad i said your dad
would say about jesus yeah he says why
are drugs bad to use so you got to be
kidding me he says no then he would say
what's wrong with me using drugs what's
wrong with me drinking as much as i want
what's wrong with rich people are rich
people greedy he said it was constantly
debate constantly debate
i put the fault of this and this is not
gonna you know some people are not gonna
be happy about this
when kids are panicking about climate
change you know whose responsibility
that is the head of the household they
don't have these conversations with them
okay the head of the household needs to
in today's climate if you really want to
raise your kids to be strong leaders
today the head of the household has to
be very aware of what's going on and be
willing to have these conversations with
them because if you don't
and they go you're essentially handing
your kids over
to teachers to raise them with a mindset
that they want to raise them rather than
you yeah you're going to say work hard
do this be a good person go to church
whatever some of the things parents say
but you got to get a little bit deeper i
think these conversations need to happen
what happens when you when you teach
your kids what you want and as let's say
you indoctrinate them into your values
et cetera et cetera et cetera then you
send them off for four years and they
come back completely different and their
values have done a complete 180. but i'm
not indoctrinating in my specifically
in my uh values i'm indoctrinating in a
way of
processing issues not necessarily values
i'm telling you what are my my values
and principles here's what we live by
the david family lives by lead respect
improve love we don't bully we don't get
bullied we pray for courage wisdom
tolerance understanding this is what we
do as a family this is what i encourage
you to do but you you ask the why
question why do you like this morning
dylan he's reading a book he comes up to
me he's reading a world cup book and in
the world cup book he reads about a
story of hitler that in 1933 world cup
1932 whatever the world cup was hitler's
aspiration was to be like mussolini he
says dad do you realize what this hitler
every book i'm reading about hitler is
terrible i said what do you think about
this guy did that this this guy's a
terrible guy if he did this i said why
don't you go figure out why he hated
jews so much
so i should go figure i said go
researcher find out for yourself and
tell me but it's not saying
you know you're you're feeding and then
saying go find out and then come back
i'm teaching you to go find out for
yourself yeah it's critical thinking
yeah you're teaching this you're not
teaching this is the way we are and
that's it now you're you're going to
have a kid fight you later on okay
you're teaching them how to process
issues and i want to read the story to
you guys and it's going to be part of
this conversation i want to get your
feedback so new york times
children have fallen way behind in
reading
and that could put their futures at risk
last spring as it was becoming clear
that the pandemic learning
loss was real and a serious problem for
some kids there were some voices
suggesting the best approach to the
problem was to not test for it
brilliant idea right and some educations
professionals went further
and claimed that standardized tests
weren't really measuring all the good
things
kids kept out of school were learning
the president-elect teachers union
outright said there is no such thing as
learning the laws she continued it's
okay that our babies may not have
learned all their times uh tables they
learned resilience they learned survival
they learned critical thinking skills
they know the difference between a riot
and a protest they know the words
insurrection and cool oh my god that's
just that's oh my goodness now the new
york times reports that in virginia one
case study found that
uh early reading skills were at a
20-year low
this fall which researchers described as
alarming in the boston region 60 percent
of students at some high poverty schools
have been identified as at high risk for
reading problems twice the number of
students
as before the pandemic thoughts
so my husband took my 13 month old
daughter to our local library because
who doesn't love that and this was like
a week or two ago and he walks in the
library walks over to the children's
section she because she likes to read
books already she's she's actually like
that since she was like eight or nine
months
and
as soon as they got to the children's
section the children's librarian came
over to them and said sir you have to
wear a mask
and he said oh what do you mean to who
you're my husband
my husband's like oh why there's nobody
in here and i'm not sick and the
librarian was just like oh that's our
policy now we live in a state where it's
been lifted there's no mass mandate this
is a public library we funded my husband
was like oh why is it your policy and
the librarian was like do you want to
talk to the library manager and my
husband's like yes i do
so he the library manager comes down
and says oh sir it's our policy that you
have to wear a mask my husband goes may
i ask why
and he said well because that's what the
cdc says that's the cdc guidance and my
husband's like sure but i'm not sick
i've already had coveted twice i have
natural immunity you're not sick even
the cdc says cloth cloth masks aren't
effective anymore so why and the only
thing that this library manager could
say was well that's what the cdc says
that's what the cdc says and so we're
talking about this afterward and we're
we're it's just i mean first of all it's
really annoying right it's very annoying
but it's also just so fundamentally
telling about this lack of critical
thinking and the lack of critical
thinking people don't think for
themselves they don't acknowledge that
oh because the cdc is supposedly higher
on the hierarchy than we are we the
sorry people are that they could be
wrong that they shouldn't just be obeyed
that they that you could it's okay to be
skeptical and i mean this this ties into
teaching teaching children
to critically think and not just to echo
certain beliefs that's not what liberals
think anymore they don't want children
to they don't care about children
learning the times tables because what
is mathematics unless you're gonna be an
engineer it's a way of disciplining your
mind to learn how to you know put
variables together and draw a conclusion
that's it's how to it's logic right they
don't want children to learn that
because as soon as you learn logic as
soon as you learn how to think for
yourself then you start questioning
their authority so i know this sounds
like
a deep
a deep dark conspiracy to take over the
minds of our children but i think
parents across the country this isn't
just republicans or conservatives this
is democrats and liberals who are seeing
the disservice that's being done to our
children and understanding that listen
if we want to if we want our country to
be what it is we have to take this back
this is not what we want for our kids
tom what do you think about this as a
parent how do you process this well
there's two sides there the educational
side and then the home side the
enablement side and the for and on the
enablement side we become a video based
society look at the internet the
internet is very video based and the
amount of depth of articles it's hard to
find them medium has them slate has them
and conservative places have them but
that's not where the traffic is the
traffic is for video and short burst and
so there is short attention span theater
going on throughout the lives so it's
hard to get a child to
take the time and sit and read i mean
you see it as a parent pat it's getting
increasingly difficult to get your kid
to sit for 45 minutes 30 minutes 45
minutes and actually focus and read so
the first problem is the video based
society and not reinforcing the value of
reading and doing it for parents that
have the resources to do so the other
side of it is that the the schools and
the types of of books and resources are
available in the disciplines that
they're putting in in the children to do
that
because they're not emphasizing on
reading the test scores are dropping for
not for any other reason in that the
number of minutes that they spend
reading is dropping that's why the test
scores are dropping so now the tests are
bad so there's two sides of the problem
is how they're educating intentionally
and then the other side is parents have
to be active participants in this and
turn off video based
you know massaging of their brain and
get them to read because reading builds
reasoning not the other way around when
you read your mind is focused to reason
with what's happening with the character
because you're not being told you're
interpreting and when you're just told
turn left turn left turn left you turn
left
so there's a couple sides to this
you know
from the la teachers union she says
outright there's no such thing as
learning loss i think she's absolutely
incorrect on that if you're not reading
and you're not studying and you're not
focusing on school
yeah you're going to forget some stuff
you're not going to improve on stuff and
across the united states you can see the
public schools there's how many schools
are just failing or not getting good
grades but i will say she does have a
point on one thing
that
you know there's a we talked about this
yesterday at lunch there is a difference
between iq and eq book smarts and street
smarts so you know again this comes down
to parenting and what you're doing with
your kids at home are you like for
instance i don't care what you're the
schools are doing you're making your
kids read but if they're spending more
your kids i'm sure yeah i mean you have
a
13 year old that is already you know uh
major books apparently is but yeah by
herself she reads them yeah exactly so
but i you know there there there is
something to be said that during a
pandemic like this when there's a lot of
different stuff going on
and a lot of the world is changing so
fast
you know having conversations with your
kids like hey this is what's going on
critical thinking like you talked about
there's there needs to be a lot more
critical thinking with your kids at home
why are you home right now are you going
to hang out with your friends is it
worth hanging out with your friends i
don't know you're going to get sickening
with your friends are you is it worth
going to school what do you think about
zoom
street smarts is is a real thing you
know i you know you you know quite
candidly talk about how you had a 1.8
gpa but you were very popular in school
you were good at sports you were very
high on street smarts and math there's a
difference here though i was around
people
i was around people i was not uh uh uh
and you know parents still have to work
and it was a very weird 18 months for
the average parent forget about the the
people that have money they figured out
a way to get a nanny or two but the
parents were still in school it was a
mess so you you have to know that for
them to use that as an excuse to say our
kids learned about
what was the thing we learned about that
learning about
interactions is is sort of absolutely
testing again right riots
rather than uh
teaching some things so no i i
understand what you're saying i
understand what you're saying with the
point she's making that hey there's more
things to iq than you got to get good at
eq all this other stuff no i want you to
learn logically to make better decisions
that's what i want you to learn okay as
a kid
my my dad taught me how to think that
was his thing it was teaching me how to
think you know one of the things we
talked about i made a video a few years
ago saying 15 things they don't teach
you at school if i ever ran a school
the next 20 years we're doing media the
last 20 years if we ever decide to start
a university or a high school if we ever
did and it was a private school we would
be teaching certain things that these
guys don't want to teach we would teach
you how taxes work the specific tax code
and why entrepreneurs pay
taxes because of the sacrifices they
take and versus deciding to be an
entrepreneur there's different dynamics
we teach you how to sell we teach you
how to lead we teach you how money works
we teach how to negotiate we teach you
how to think for yourself we teach you
how to start a business we teach how to
earn millions how to process issues how
to marry no one's teaching you how to
marry what is this marriage thing all
about you get married all of a sudden
like holy moly i don't have a manual for
this
how many marriage books do i need to
read by people that have been divorced
seven times what do i need to learn to
how so i want to sit i want to have a
panel of a husband and wife that i've
been married for 40 years i want a panel
of a person that's been divorced three
times i want a panel of a person that's
newly wet and i want them to debate
somebody that doesn't believe in
marriage and a single 55 years old why
let the kids say i kind of lean towards
this guy i don't want to get married i
kind of lean towards this side i'm
afraid this guy got a divorce but i
learned we're not doing these things so
for them to say
we learned the difference between a coup
and an insurrection
who gave us [ __ ] about that at 10 years
old 11 12 years old what are we talking
about so is that what we're feeding into
their minds being the most important the
classes you're talking about goes to my
point is that those are street smart
type things those are emotional
intelligence things yeah marriage
entrepreneurship how to make money
that's not iq you can't do anything
algebra 2.
you can't do no but algebra but math is
very much about processing trigonometry
i think math analysis is about
processing issues
because it is all the way through
calculus i fully agree i think you know
the whole thing about einstein would say
the difference between
somebody wins and somebody doesn't like
prefacing what he said it was the
successful people stay with problems
longer right math is about i can't
figure this freaking thing out how the
hell does this work you stay with the
problem longer you solve it then for the
rest of your life you're having a
problem in a business and a relationship
and a friendship you stay with the
problem longer you figure it out rather
than saying i'm just not working out
boom here's what i'm doing i think math
is all that anyways
we learn by being around each other we
learn by being around each other we
learn by this discourse right the kids
lost that 18 months most middle low
income people in california new york
they lost it scores in boston 60 it's
pathetic anyways i'll give you the last
word yeah no i mean i think what you're
talking about with taxes so this is one
of the reasons that i am as passionately
conservative as i am i mean you
mentioned at the beginning we were
talking right before we went on air
about my twitter mention feed because i
mean it's just a cesspool in there it's
not all roses and unicorns there's a lot
of people that are upset and you know
that that can be an intimidating thing
that can be something that that people
have trouble handling and that's not
been something that i have cowered away
from that's been something that i've
accepted as part of my job and the re
one of the reasons for that is exactly
what you mentioned because my dad is a
small business owner and when i mean i
can remember when i was like 10 years
old he paid me five bucks to help him do
his taxes like i've been doing i was
doing taxes with him right but that's
awesome right i love that and so i knew
how to do my own taxes as soon as as
soon as i got a job i did it myself i
did it quickly and you know you you gain
an understanding then for how something
as
intangibly sounding to a child as the
tax code concretely impact your family
in your life so i understood then wow if
this if this politician is promising to
raise the corporate tax code like that's
going to have a negative impact on my
dad's business god that's so important
to teach but that's such a boring topic
unless you have a hands-on experience
exactly and so i learned very young okay
so this is something like i'm fiscally
conservative because i see how it
impacts my dad which means how it
impacts me and all my sisters and
brother and my mom
um and
i think you have to have that kind of
imprint on your on your emotional
intelligence as well as on your iq and
the the other reason not to not to wax
too philosophically here the other
reason that i am so conservative too and
the reason that i'm so comfortable being
a skeptic in all areas um
is is because when i was in late high
school i was diagnosed i was i was
actually a competitive swimmer i was a
pretty elite swimmer i was diagnosed
with a cell disease it's an autoimmune
issue and at the time i mean there
weren't there weren't many options the
doctors were just like okay you're gonna
have to live with this it wasn't really
a livable thing and my mom was like well
i'm not gonna accept that like i'm gonna
go search for
search for something alternative and
thank god she was able to you know find
an alternative way for me to manage my
health which i managed to this day but i
realized again that if we didn't live in
the type of economy the type of free
market that we live in my and my dad
hadn't had the choice to be super smart
with his finances and have a lot of
savings we wouldn't have been able to
afford
the treatment that ultimately saved my
life
that's something that has a really big
impact on you as like in your formative
years very emotional yeah that you know
sometimes uh
you you the the money stuff like you
make money and i've owned all the crazy
cars and all that stuff i live in a
beautiful home all the you know people
to have dinner with
but the basic things about money i had
one of our guys marroquin boris maroquin
he was at the house we're having a cigar
together
salvadorian husband and wife love these
guys
and he's sitting next to me and we're
talking
and he starts crying
i said what's up what what's on your
mind he said well let me tell you what
happened you know
uh i used to not make a lot of money and
now making very good money and he had
made like 70 grand that month he says uh
you know i thought it's about the cars
and all this stuff he bought his body
bought his wife and escalade and his him
and his wife have been together for 25
years and he says but you know what was
crazy what there was a health issue that
happened with my kid and we needed to
spend six thousand dollars and it's very
private and we have to spend six
thousand dollars on the kid he says i
had no if it was a year and a half ago
two years ago
i wouldn't be able to do anything with
that i'd have to figure out a way to
make this i i was able to pay that six
thousand dollars he says to me
capitalism is that yeah that's
capitalism capitalism isn't another
three hundred 000 watch capitalism isn't
another half a million dollar that's
capitalism now what we have to consider
i grew up in a family where my mom was
on welfare and we didn't have money
how we help those that don't have access
to the resources with parents
that maybe you had like some people
don't have that
what do we do with them because those
parents
maybe don't have the resources that we
have to figure right away like you know
speaking to a school and they were
talking about how can we make our kids
uh better at processing issues and
there's this the director of psychology
the school's having this conversation
with me i said how often do you guys
have
a training just for parents what do you
mean like how often do you bring just
parents in all together in the
auditorium and talk to the parents about
how to talk to the kids at night and how
to have conversations with them at night
oh we never do that what do you mean you
never do that you know that in sales
it's about training the trainer that
whole saying train the trainer well who
is the trainer here the parent
we need to train the trainers the
parents as much as we're training the
kids i think we're spending way too much
time focused on the kids and we're
forgetting about the fact that that
parent is sitting there without access
to resources can you just teach me what
to do and by the way let's just say 600
parents do show up and let's just say 80
percent of the parents sit there like
this right and they're not even paying
attention to anything you're saying but
say 20 percent that do of the 20 percent
that do 20 take notes and go back and
apply them one of the kids ends up
becoming a positive impact to society
and less personal relying on government
for taxes and resources we did our part
so i think there needs to be just as
much training with parents as there is
it's very powerful i think you're
absolutely correct and you know where it
is happening today it's happening today
in the american homeschooling
communities so people think oh
homeschooling so if your dad happened to
be a pharmacist maybe he teaches
chemistry you know the homeschoolers
turn to resources they have resources
standardized testing they can get and
books and things like that but then they
turn to the other parents who's the
expert on what and they do some of the
teaching for the kids and they go to
each it's almost like going to class oh
you're going to go to mr richardson's
house and learn about chemistry because
he's a pharmacist well guess what's also
happening parents are getting together
and the parents are becoming educated on
social issues and becoming more aware
and
handling
discovering adhd or thing or dyslexia
and how to handle it and manage it so it
happens in the homeschooling environment
because the parents are forming
communities because they know that
there's things they don't know and
there's gaps and they want to learn it
pat that's where it's happening and i
think
a little conspiracy theory that
the society the left is less worried
about homeschooling because of vouchers
and they're more worried about
homeschooling because of voters because
the parents are being changed it's not
the indoctrination of tomorrow's voters
they're being taught wrong i think the
parents are more independent heads up
and they are learning in groups fyi
you you know you know how all these guys
right now have uh courses online i do
course on marriage i do course on you
know such and such i do whatever the
different courses you can buy on udemy
pluralsight all these different things
you know what's a great niche that
people can take on right now that will
do very well
small courses on how to lead your kids
specific on leading your kids
i don't know how much that is out there
anyways let me go to the next one i was
home thanks for the suggestion i gotta
go but let me let me say i think that's
a great idea that we do here at
valuetainment this is i mean this is
exactly why you do the sls symposium the
sales leadership symposium is that you
talk about you know why don't they do
courses to teach parents same thing you
do with train the trainers with php same
thing you do with sls i assume that's
the reason you do that is who's teaching
the sales leader to reinvent themselves
right or to by the way you don't you
know how much duplicate themselves you
know how much i would do this course
let's just say we do a parenting course
i do it for 10 bucks 20 bucks because
you want the masses you want people to
get it hey here's
here's some strategies that worked on me
here's some strategies i'm using with my
kids i want to share it with you we
can't rely on the teachers to do it we
got to become better parents so the idea
is to train the parents if you're up for
it let's go through it if you disagree
with me fine maybe some of these tactics
are going to work i think there is a
market for that let me lead to the next
story this all confining the kids leads
to what here's a daily mail story party
like it's 2019. florida and fort
lauderdale expects triple the amount of
visitors over the last years tens of
thousands prepared to celebrate the
first spring break in the u.s free of
covet rules thousands of college
students and visitors are descending on
florida's beaches not california but
florida this week to celebrate the first
spring break without any coronavirus
restrictions since 2019 inhabitants of
popular vacation spots including cancun
miami pensacola fort lauderdale the
south padre island have to deal with
observing never-ending crowds of college
students having a good time often
blasting loud music and drinking alcohol
from the first week of march until april
starting on saturday until march 20th
many public schools districts in florida
including pan uh penn uh pennios
hillsborough pasco et cetera et cetera
as well as the last university of
southern florida and tap on will be on
vacation last year spring break saw 65
000 passengers fly into tampa bay
international airport per day during
peak weeks however in 2020 the number of
spring breakers was dismally low in
march and april as there were fewer than
1500 flights a day versus 65
foul so people are about to start
partying in
florida you're around college students a
lot what do you think about the story i
think my youngest sister who i mentioned
before who is a sophomore in college
she's a college basketball player she
came with me down here she said oh
you're going to fort lauderdale that's a
free spring break trip for me so um
she's here although i hope some of that
debauchery that you described she won't
be taking part in
um if she does i'll just you know make
her babysit i mean it's it's great in a
sense i'm not i'm not endorsing some of
the spring break footage that we see out
of florida every year but it's great
that people young people specifically
who are so prone to be vulnerable to the
fear that we were talking about with
climate change are realizing that they
don't have to be afraid of kovid they
don't have to be they don't have to stop
their lives anymore they don't have to
not associate with other people they can
just do their thing they can go to
school again they can go party again
they can go on spring break again that's
a good thing and florida of course has
been a leader a leader in uh following
the science on the covid regulations
it's it's that's why i've come to
florida so many times in the past year
just to get away from get away from some
of the policies in a blue state but um
it's good i i was really encouraged to
hear the surgeon general of florida say
that they're not going to encourage
vaccines covered vaccines for healthy
children that's what the science says
that's that's that's really nice
you said yeah she called him a
politician
yeah so they asked her that he was
propagating conspiracies yeah what do
you think about florida you know uh not
uh
agreeing with kids taking the vaccine uh
do you agree with them absolutely not
what's your answer absolutely the
science we have the science the true
science and the true science tells us
that you know vaccine for kids
uh anyway so yeah so that's what's gonna
found the way to say even death in the
next 90 seconds
three times
it's it's uh even death the currency of
fear is very effective it's worked for
centuries ever you know it's been used
for so many years
and they're using it very eloquently but
people in florida especially with ron de
santa he's getting a lot of did you see
him uh the other day with the whole
masking with the kids
i don't appreciate you guys having a
mask on anyways if you're going to wear
it just you know yeah there's a mask
okay there you go so
good to be here in florida
did you see their faces when they took
the masks off though they thought there
was like one or two that were horrified
but the rest of them were like
yeah i saw that yeah but that's what
they need they need a strong leader to
tell them like it's okay to take your
face mask by the way things are going
about about to get very insane down here
in south florida now as a true
conservative i very rarely go visit
south beach and party past midnight
that's something i've definitely not
known to do uh however the few times
that i have gone down to south beach
during the day over the last few years
like last year i went down and i and i
did a man on the street piece
uh about spring break stimulus spending
and it was i was interviewing all the
people it was a really sexy topic
exactly and it was just all the people
that were getting stimulus checks that
were just like where else are they going
to go florida obviously these weren't
necessarily college kids at that time
there was just people getting stimulus
checks yo we're going to south beach
we're going to fort lauderdale about to
have the time of our lives that's going
to get amplified times 10. now it's like
you know gloves are off you know flights
are back
we're going to party in south beach so
just be very
weary and hopefully your 19 year old
sister doesn't party too hard well i
disagree with the debauchery of spring
break i absolutely disagree with that
however it's very interesting that greg
abbott and ron desantis their states are
going to get tax revenue visitors and
local businesses are getting a lot of
patronage in the hospitality hotels
restaurants and things are getting a lot
of dollars and florida and texas and
those entrepreneurs running those places
are cash what do you mean you disagree
with the debauchery first of all i
disagree with the debauchery but you've
got a but you have a wave of commerce
that's coming to ron desantis and greg
abbott first of all thanks for spring
break when tom's podcast gets started
his number one sponsor is going to be a
cbd oil company yeah or a beer tom is
going to
today's message is brought to you by cbd
oil from boca raton uh our friends over
here you know bring the best best see
anyways going back to debauchery when i
was in the army okay
fourth of july we were at panama city
okay
memorial day weekend panama city you
know
whatever labor day panama city in the
army they would call it a danza we would
come down here and it was an incredible
time incredible time we read a lot of
books we went to all the local borders
we were very committed
no drinking no fighting no girls nothing
yes it's going to be i have a feeling
it's going to be a bigger number than
they even expect it to be
which i'm sure you support that because
you probably can't wait to go out there
and spend i'll be down there with our
friend david doing some interviews at
model volleyball this weekend if you're
in south florida
come check us out what's her name shout
out to her father what's uh olivia ormos
my girl yeah she's putting together a
model if you're in south florida this
weekend be in south beach for model
volleyball it's going to be epic but biz
doc you're not invited because it'll be
a little too debaucherous for your
little taste okay little guy all right
so here we go
here we go he's going gonna come back
don't worry just be patient all right so
let's let's talk a little oil and gas
let's talk oil and gas because it is a
topic by the way did you see the
inflation numbers that just came out
this morning 7.9 that they're telling us
which is the highest in decades uh 7.9
percent gas prices record breaking guy
sends me pic yesterday i was talking
about gas uh the price of it everybody's
sending me a message with what gas
prices are in different places beverly
hills 7-eleven
seven seven eleven seven eleven in
beverly hills glendale was like 679
to fill up one gallon is 679. uh what
was i go back to it's 7.9 percent
40-year uh record that we have on your
instagram yeah so so here's russia with
oil russia with oil okay i want to read
two stories back to back and i will
comment on it because it's uh both
around the same thing one is an insider
story
and the other one is a cnbc story so
here we go uh number one opec chief says
there's no capacity in the world that
could replace russia seven million
barrels a day in supply this is an
insider's story russian oil experts are
crucial to global supply and there's no
sources that can compensate for the
millions of barrels the country
contributes opec secretary general has
said so far opec and its allies known as
opec plus have shown no interest in
ramping up production leading some
analysts to say that this is
contributing to the squeeze on supply
the threat on an o on an import ban
prompted russia's deputy minister
to issue a warning and predicts oil
prices could search two ready folks
three hundred dollars a barrel and the
story right afterwards cnbc russia wants
300 a barrel it is absolutely clear that
a rejection of russian oil would lead to
catastrophic consequences for the global
market
russian deputy prime minister alexander
novak said on monday let me read this
one more time to you this is a power
play i want to read it to you one more
time folks listen up this is the russian
deputy prime minister alexander novak
said on monday okay it is absolutely
clear that a rejection of russian oil
would lead to catastrophic consequences
for the global market the surge in
prices would be unpredictable it would
be 300
per barrel if not more russia's the
third largest oil producer behind u.s
saudi but u.s doesn't count because
we're not doing anything saudi arabia
didn't return
a biden's call when they reached out to
him they just didn't even call him back
and the european union received around
40 of its gas via russian pipelines
several of which run through ukraine
once again eu 40 is through russia so
thoughts on what's going on with gas
prices have you seen those stickers that
have been popping up all over the
country on gas tanks it's like a little
silhouette of biden pointing to the
price that says i did this
i think that's exactly correct this is
not russia's fault this is biden's fault
this is biden's fault because he could
have prevented what's happening between
russia and ukraine this this is this is
not something that just arbitrarily
happened this is this is a result the
war that's happening between russian
ukraine right now is a result of
deliberate actions taken by joe biden
and what i mean by that is just a couple
months ago if he had stopped the key or
if he had stopped the nordstrom 2
pipeline if he had put sanctions like
trump did on that pipeline then russia
would have backed off
biden
personally lobbied democratic senators
not to reimpose those sanctions so what
happens obviously then putin is
emboldened because he knows that there
are countries like germany who rely on
him for energy meaning they're not going
to criticize him when he
commits a war act against the ukrainians
right but it goes even deeper than that
it goes deeper than that because
russian money has been funding the
environmentalist agenda in our country
for years and this is not this is not
like exclusive journalism that i'm
presenting to you this is actually
something we have known about when i say
we i mean our government officials back
in 2017 there were two republican
congressmen the story is so fascinating
to me there were two republican
congressmen smith and weber who sent a
letter to secretary of the treasury
mnuchin saying listen we have evidence
that russian state money is going
through a shell company in bermuda the
shell company is called klein limited
and klein limited is then giving as
anonymous donations to um a 501c3 here
in the united states giving this money
to an organization called sea change sea
change is then disseminating this money
to
prominent anti-fracking anti-fossil fuel
so-called green
organizations here in our country and
the purpose of this is like vladimir
putin has been planning this attack on
ukraine for a long time this has been a
long time in the preparation because
this has worked this lobbying has worked
it has caused states across our country
to ban fracking it's caused biden to
take his stance against fracking against
using our natural resources against the
federal leases and the result of this
has been well of course when we turn to
winter solar or anything alternative or
renewable it we still rely on coal we
still rely on oil right even even with
this green energy but when we need to
rely on oil and we're not producing it
ourselves we have to rely on russian oil
and that gives that gives a position of
leverage to vladimir putin he knows then
about it that he can
he can
invade ukraine and that nobody can
really do anything about it because they
rely on him and so when i see i know
this is a long answer to your short
question of please rant about the gas
prices but this is not something that
just arbitrarily happened this is not
something that happened overnight this
is the result of deliberate bad corrupt
choices by our politicians for a long
time for a long time
you see what uh john bolton had to say
about this situation you know who john
bolton is right the national security
adviser the most famous mustache yeah
yeah the walrus man who was trump's
national security adviser now you might
say
they've had a falling out but he's
certainly a republican he's certainly
part of that community for sure he said
quote unquote
um that they were asked why did this is
his thoughts not mine
why did
putin delay
this invasion of ukraine he said quote
unquote putin delayed the invasion of
ukraine because putin saw what trump was
doing was doing a lot of his dirty work
for him that trump was basically being
um
hostile towards nato and he basically
thought
that
uh if he won a second term there was a
chance that
trump would pull out of nato so putin
was basically just biding his time you
know play on words right there buying
his time to see if trump would actually
pull out of nato now
whether he was going to do that or not
there was no doubt that he was hostile
towards nato and this is sort of
separate from the gas prices but this is
a direct answer to why putin chose this
time but this was john bolton's opinion
do you have any strong feelings on what
john bolton has to say or well john
bolton and donald trump are on opposite
ends of the republican party and what i
mean by that is there's a dike there's a
division especially when it comes to
foreign policy there's interventionists
like john bolton they're like certainly
not a dove he's a definite warrior no he
wants to attack iran
i mean he would admit this this isn't he
said it on camera yeah yeah and then
donald trump was very much national
interest he called it america first it's
really a reagan foreign policy but he
didn't want to get involved anywhere
unless he has to unless it's in our
direct national interest it's actually
closer to the isolationist end of the
spectrum um i think i think john bolton
actually misses misses the point here i
don't think that trump was hostile to
nato i think that that was a negotiation
tactic to get nato members to pay their
fair share the u.s has been paying the
majority of dues to nato for a long time
and all of these other countries have
been freeloaders they've been taking
advantage of us as they they have enough
money they've just been using it for
their own domestic welfare systems and
just allowing the us to do it because we
would to pay this amount because we
would and so trump is calling them out
he's forcing them he's threatening them
as a negotiation tactic sure he probably
meant it all good negotiation like when
you when you make a threat like that you
have to follow through it's not a real
threat people can sense that
um but i don't think that he ever had
any real intention of pulling out of
nato i think that he was just using this
to get people to pay and it worked they
did pay well john you you expect john to
say anything about trump
you expect bolton to say anything good
about trump right now you know he was
his national security adviser
you remember his book but that but that
same thing with bill barr now same thing
with pence now yeah he has these people
that are sick offense to him and then
next thing you know they're out and they
talk [ __ ] about him it just seems to be
a common theme is all i'm saying right
but you step back to where this topic
started which was on you know
international oil prices there is a cold
war that's been going on for the last 25
years since the price of oil it is a
cold war that's going on between saudis
and the u.s between saudis and venezuela
between the cheaters that are in opec
that are shipping and not telling the
other opec people remember it was the
saudis that wanted to [ __ ] alberta
oil sands and north dakota oil sand and
shale oil by keeping the price of a
barrel at 45 they they acted against
their own
total profit and pulled the price all
the way down there now why'd they do
that well they do that because you know
alberta and north dakota were not
economically feasible oil extraction
below 50 a barrel
now with the price per barrel up this is
exact time where biden can flip the
switch on energy independence where does
canada get 100 of its natural gas us the
united states now you could sit back and
say you know what let's loosen up on
this let's listen up on it and saki
yesterday that was a terribly
disingenuous answer that she gave on
this whole energy question well they've
you know they have the leases lisa's is
not a permit a permit takes forever in
washington elise's is that you have a
right to drill once you get a permit to
drill but the permits live in washington
and they the green drag feed on that so
when you look around on the oil stuff
pat this has been going back and forth
for a while and then putin's three-step
process here also was benefiting the
price and the need for the russian oil
but we gotta
also realize why those saudis didn't
return joe biden's phone call by the way
they've been playing with us for a while
as well nothing but it's not funny it's
not funny
i'm going to read the story to you so uh
saudi uae leaders declined calls with
biden amid ukraine conflict this is a
hill story yesterday two days ago there
was some expectation of a phone call but
it didn't happen a u.s official told
the wall street journal regarding a call
between biden and saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman it was part of
turning
on the spigot of saudi oil uae leader
sheikh mohammed
it also declined a call from biden
officials say the u.s relations with the
two gulf countries have been strained
over the biden administration's lack of
support in the war in yemen
and the revived negotiation concerning
the iran nuclear deal saudi arabia has
also been pushing for legal immunity in
the u.s for crown prince mohammed who is
accused of killing a journalist in 2018.
so you got to realize foreign relations
is for people to pick up your calls to
talk to you
and and do something with you so these
guys when is the last time you heard a
story that somebody says
yeah u.s you know you're historically
been the greatest country in the world
the president wants to talk to you you
know what i'm going to keep playing this
xbox just tell by not call him back
later maybe send him a message or
something some flowers but we got some
things to do and then
you hear the questions people say
uh
your gas prices is all because of uh
russia okay if you can pull back what
you had the three pictures i send you
the two pig yeah
david if you can pull this one up and
they say gas prices is because of russia
okay
that's when biden was sworn in
okay gas prices were 2
30
2 40. do you see that that's when he was
sworn in okay
putin invaded
when gas prices were at 351.
this is not a russia thing folks
this went from 240
to 350 that's a buck 10 on 240 that's 45
it went up in a year and a half a little
over a year and a half two years
during the administration is that a
byproduct of what's going on there now
if you look at it now it went from 351
to 412 and it's going to get higher
i see this thing getting higher i've
already made my prediction seven eight
months ago right the gas prices are
gonna hit ten bucks a gallon uh and some
are even saying right now it's gonna hit
15 bucks a gallon by the way there's a
video can you go to the next slide so
they can see some of the pictures this
is glendale california 669.
go to the next one this is beverly hills
can you zoom in a little bit so people
can't see it it's 7 29 for a 91
in beverly hills there's a gas station
right across the street john reed was
telling the story yesterday in the pdp
podcast prep meeting he said the guy's
telling me fill up your gas tank now
while it's 4 19. it's going to be 490 by
midnight and by later on tonight fill it
up right now there's a person that did a
video
standing in front of a gas station
recording a video
seeing the prices go
401 402. 403. 404. for
what i'm saying live they're recording
it while they're filling up the tank the
prices per gallon is going up while it's
filling up the tank
it's like a stock you're at the gas
price on the tank it's like a stock
market it's a security stock market so
the guys are telling you buy and fill up
your tank
now we should teach our kids supply and
demand can you go back to the biden
chart real quick
thank you t take a look at the immediate
you see how the curve immediately jumps
after the inauguration pat it's like
real steep and then it kind of levels
out the reason it did that was this okay
no more keystone and limiting american
drilling that creates what a shortage in
supply actually reduces supply which
increases price so the economy works
exactly the way but that was him cow
towing to the greens on keystone
pipeline and drilling in the u.s and you
saw immediately upon being inaugurated
he put pressure on the american people
and gas prices immediately it just jumps
up and then it's a more gentle increase
until the big fun starts with ukraine
who who who hurts this the most who's
hurting right now the average average
the average the the low income people
obviously you know i'll go one step
further the lower cost housing is
farther from city center but the jobs
are in city center the commuting times
hits the middle and lower class worse
than it does the upper class and so when
this happens you're hurting the people
that can least afford it
why is it that
politicians
who create policies to help the low and
middle income
are the ones that end up directly and
indirectly hurting the community that
they claim that they want to help can
you go to my twitter profile yesterday
bernie sanders said
something about
how much money the billionaires and
whatever millionaires made in the last
uh
uh
12 to 18 months during the pandemic i
don't know if you can pull it up anyways
i i responded back to him saying this is
a again byproduct of uh i'll just read
it to you right here since you're i'll
i'll
printing the money now here's what i
told him so he said this is a this is
oligarchy this is greek this is
callousness last year over two million
go to what he had to say go go to his
tweet and then you'll go back right
there yeah yeah this is callousness last
year over two million can you zoom in a
little bit so audience can see it over
two million people worldwide died of
hunger at the same time the world's 2.2
uh 2755 billionaire saw their net net
worth or wealth go up 5 trillion
from 8.6 trillion to 13.8 trillion this
is why we need a tax on wealth okay now
go back in this is my responses three
parts i said that's what happens when
you print money and give handouts to
people who don't know how to manage
money they buy products from companies
started by entrepreneurs money flows up
stimulus money rolled up to billionaires
they'd love another round bernie go a
little lower
and then i said step number one of
helping low and middle income families
is to teach them how money works teach
them how to create an additional source
of income teach them to read the right
books instead of watching netflix
which politician is talking about that
today no one go below and the last one
why not because vote because those votes
may start thinking for themselves if we
truly care about the loan middle-income
families let's help them graduate the
poverty mindset instead of being stuck
there that's what great leaders do they
leave you better than they found you
this leads me to the story of one and a
half trillion dollars they want to print
again
so i don't know if you guys saw the
story page number six if you want to go
to it lawmakers
uh reach a deal on one and a half
trillion dollar spending bill to avoid
shutdown and aid to ukraine okay
leaders reached a bipartisan deal early
wednesday on a one and a half trillion
dollar spending bill needed to avert a
government shutdown the legislation
includes 13.6 billion dollar aid
to ukraine folks that's kind of like us
getting a hundred thousand dollar loan
and i say i'm here to help you and i
give you
thirteen thousand dollars okay i said
hey uh not thirteen thousand dollars
thirteen hundred dollars so i get a
hundred thousand dollar loan because i'm
doing this for you because your family i
care about you guys so my ukraine we
really wanna help you here's a hundred
thousand dollars we get i give you 1300
bucks ukraine like 13.6 billion eight to
ukraine or european allies and 15.6
billion of funding for cove 19 vaccines
testing treatments in the united states
and abroad president biden had requested
10 billion dollars for ukraine and
european allies and 22 and a half
billion dollars for covet relief
lawmakers face a friday deadline to pass
the spending measure and avoid a weekend
government shutdown let's print some
more money tom what do you think about
this i think it's horrible i just did
the math on this so basically
everybody listening average americans
13.6 billion to ukrainian and european
allies okay there's a war going on over
there it's very very important but every
man woman and nipple-sucking child in
this country just gave 418 dollars to
ukraine
every one of them so when you start to
put it in that thing you say wow we did
yep and you take 1.5 trillion
that's basically what's at 4600.
this is crazy i mean this is
this is debt ceiling you know if my mom
had never said this to me hey kids
listen part of your inheritance you have
to inherit our credit card and deal with
it and pay it off
and to avert a family shutdown we're
increasing the credit limit by 10 grand
so that your dad and i can take an
anniversary trip to hawaii
i would have been like wait a minute can
you get back to the part where i inherit
your credit card so if you were to put
it that way let's make a story about a
perspective make a storybook for six
years old
your parents said we're gonna increase
the debt ceiling for the family so your
dad and i can go to hawaii and then when
when we die remember you're responsible
for the credit card because
debt never dies liz what do you think
about this i think it's actually bigger
than that because i don't think that
there's an expectation
from the left at least that we are all
or our children are all actually going
to pay this you guys know what modern
monetary theory is modern monetary
theory is this very radical leftist
philosophy that you don't have to worry
about the debt or the deficit that you
can that a government when the
government is the issuer of the currency
can and should just print as much money
as they need and that the deficit and
the debt are just a historical record of
how much has been printed and i think
modern monetary policy is something that
has actually been happening in our
country for
obviously not just this administration
not just not just liberal
administrations actually bush obama
trump now biden all of these all these
administrations have spent an exorbitant
amount of money but what happens is
under modern monetary policy not only is
that obviously going to lead to economic
ruin that's almost the secondary part of
it the point of modern monetary policy
is so that politicians at the federal
level in our legislature don't have to
ask themselves the questions how do we
fund our pet projects we have this this
ideological
smorgasbord in in a bill like this we
don't have to actually sit here and
debate in front of the american people
where do we get the money from this is
this worth spending your paycheck on all
they have to do is print the money so
this this modern monetary policy by the
way one of the propagators of modern
monetary policy one of the the lead
thinkers on this is named stephanie
kelton stephanie calton is an advisor to
the biden administration and was an
adviser to both bernie sanders and joe
biden during their campaigns so this
modern monetary policy is is
acknowledged and embraced by the biden
administration they just hope that you
won't notice they hope you won't notice
because this is the way they push their
agenda through this is the way that it
can never be rolled back because our
legislators then don't actually have to
take into consideration whether they're
being wise whether people want their
money spent on a b or c policy whether
they want it spent on the green new deal
or whether they want it spent on
medicare for all or whether they want it
spent on ukraine they don't have to our
legislators never have to debate that
because people in a sense don't touch
that
they yes we will we will have economic
ruin eventually but right now it's just
their way of pushing through their
agenda and so when i see when i see a
bill like that i immediately think well
they're going to print the money because
that's the way that they push their own
agenda unless we stop their ability to
print that money they're going to keep
doing things like this can you talk a
little bit more about her is she one of
the proponents of like great reset or
jubilee or inflate out infinity
she is she's played out of debt yeah so
she she's a professor a college
professor and she i mean she just speaks
probably more bluntly than anyone else
that i've heard about modern monetary
theory being completely dismissive of
the idea that you would ever have to pay
back you would ever have to pay back um
what you're spending or that she she
actually admits that taxation
under modern monetary theory isn't about
increasing revenue for government to pay
for whatever projects they have she
thinks that taxation is a form of
control that taxation is a way to ensure
that people don't ditch the u.s dollar
um because they see that this the
spending increases you know or devalues
the dollar it it increases inflation she
says taxation is just a way to make sure
that people stay using our currency
because you have to you have to earn the
us dollar in order to pay the us dollar
as taxes and to me that was the most
shocking admission sometimes if you
listen
no it doesn't work but this is what the
people in charge of our country are
doing right now if you dig into it i
find it to be incredibly fascinating but
also incredibly frightening but you know
whose name we're about to hear that we
haven't heard in about a month right joe
manchin
because
yeah obviously this you know for people
not familiar how bills work right uh or
how laws get passed or how stimulus you
know bills end up getting in the hands
of the american people this started in
the house that does not mean that it's
going to pass the senate and everything
that we've saw with the
you know all the proposals that have
been put together in the house and then
boom the mansions of the world and the
cinemas of the world doesn't happen and
then you know all those side
conversations that really haven't
amounted to much so you know we get
caught up in the headlines that this is
what they're going to do this was going
to spend and by no means is this
actually happening so don't be surprised
if you hear joe manchin you know name
the news again and i hope so uh circle
the wagons with joe manchin well first
of all this mid mid year midterms is
going to be
i mean it's nothing is getting better
and better like you know you know what
is also scary they missed out on the op
this is going to sound crazy when i tell
you this they missed out on the
marketing opportunity of saying covet is
done
so the way they did it even as a
marketing strategist you didn't do it
the right way the the ukraine
issue debacle that's taking place over
there
they were not able to capitalize off the
marketing opportunity for biden
fauci and all of them to come out and
say folks
great news after extensive strategies
with our covet relief team and you know
vaccines and all this other stuff
everything's going back to normal we are
leaving the mask and we're leaving this
a move like that if they would have done
that two months ago or even six weeks
ago
that would have helped them for midterms
it's almost as if their marketing
strategy is is not even a smart
marketing strategist because everything
right now is what so let's just say
midterms come up what are people voting
for
gas prices what else am i voting for
inflation what else am i voting for a
war what else am i what what like what
do you what victory do you have they
have no victory right they're going to
pay price for it
from a marketing standpoint
they just tried the disappearing act
with anthony all of a sudden did you
notice he was just gone from the airway
yeah he he's such that's actually a
really good point when's the last time
you saw four that's not a good marketing
strategy they should have capitalized
off of it i was surprised biden didn't
um basically declare that kovid was over
during his state of the union i thought
he was especially because in new york
the governor said listen we're going to
take mass mandates out of school kids
aren't going to have to wear that
anymore she announced it on monday but
instead of saying it's going to go into
effect tomorrow she said wednesday and i
thought oh well biden's going gonna be
the one to announce that in the state of
union no he didn't he didn't touch on it
maybe because i mean the american people
have have seen the light in a certain
sense that i mean they're yes you're
gonna see people wearing masks
voluntarily for years to come a certain
a certain percentage of people but fauci
fauci has dipped out of the spotlight as
the spotlight has turned to those
biological labs in ukraine because
that's the part regardless of whether
you feel the fear about the virus people
don't like corruption and politicians
and they don't like that fouchy through
the nih funded the wuhan institute of
virology which perhaps perhaps this
virus was tinkered with in in that lab
they do not like that and this looks
like it could be happening again in
ukraine with the biological uh weapons
labs that the us is kind of trying to
defend against right now but can't tyler
is there something you're excited about
you want to give a shout out to our
friends at the
babylon b we love these guys so
attention star dr fauci agrees to box
jake paul what a picture right there oh
that's horrifying those guys do a
phenomenal job both of us do fantastic
this is just anecdotal weight 95.
you know what i got in the mail was that
last week what my government issued
covid testing kit came in the mail last
week like we're done with covid right
everybody kind of agrees it's just off
the radar and sure enough when i when
nobody needs it right we all get our
government did you order it or did it
just get sent to you just got said to be
interested this just showed up in the
mail i was like oh i got a package
wonder where it came from and outcomes
you know i'm offended i haven't gotten
one yet it really hurts my feelings but
by the way this whole gas thing you know
what it's doing it's what's crazy with
this one if you can pull up the picture
on this this is a fox news story gas
theft on the rise as gas prices
skyrocketed while gas prices continue to
hit record high some people in southern
california are now
resorting to gasoline theft a fox 11
viewer
shared photos of what happened to a
vehicle a thief drilled a hole in the
fuel tank draining all the gas
aaa seen a rise in gas
siphoning and theft across the country
and now they're warning car owners about
how to keep their vehicles safe this is
a sign of the times you know triple a
doug shupe said it's thieves looking for
ways that they can make money by
stealing what is becoming an
increasingly more expensive and valuable
commodity gasoline mona garcia says
she's fed up with the prices it used to
be sixty dollars then it went to seventy
dollars i think two weeks ago was ninety
dollars so i'm thinking this might hit a
hundred dollars she said while filling
up her car monday as she feared she
spent a hundred dollars to fill up the
tank garcia said her camera and the
flood light in her driveways
any would be thieves uh from taking gas
from the tank pretty crazy that's
getting to a point that people are now
stealing gas from cars this happened to
us my husband and i lived in california
for eight years we lived in san diego
and this was before the inflation
although gas has always been crazy
expensive there he has he has a project
car it's a 1988 camaro iraq z that he
would do projects on and he parked it in
our driveway which was outside and we
came out i think it was on a weekend he
had parked it there on friday night and
we came out the next morning and there
was still like the tube that the that
the thief had used to siphon the gas
that was hanging out of the tank of his
guys i i think this is as much as the
red one but it doesn't have a t-top it's
a convertible
uh listen to me talking about these car
terms thank you
uh it doesn't have a t-top it's a happy
end uh hey i listen when he's hot
isn't the engine at him it's the top of
the vehicle yeah i know
you know what's crazy here's what's
crazy so
you would think
you
doesn't have a t-top it's a hemi okay
you don't you don't think you don't
think uh uh inflation typically would
cause gas oil what do you call it gold
to go up and it hasn't printing money
would cause gold to go up and he hasn't
peter schiff must be furious right now
because oil has gone up and gold's
staying flat it's gone up a little bit
not at the numbers that you know people
are expecting
oil is beating gas folks oil is beating
uh gold uh as of right now anyways are
you guys okay if we cover this bio lab
story i don't want to offend you guys if
we go into so what's going on here with
the biology can we do a last-minute on
uh gas real quick you wanna you wanna
say something go ahead yeah where are
the highest state gas taxes in the
nation california there you go so 20 25
so
sacramento is benefiting or not
benefiting from these high gas prices
they're benefiting thank you very much
yeah by the way you know what they could
do is somebody yesterday i'm trying to
sell this i want to give them credit
somebody said yesterday to me they text
me and they said you know if they really
care about middle america so much all
they have to do is remove the gas taxes
it'll go back down to normal and they
can do that for 90 days but no they're
not going to do because they want the
taxes they want that tax money
california is uh taking a lot of money
from we're taking out of the french
laundry for a comment from gavin nissm
so let me give you a story by reuters
about biolabs and this has been going
back and forth even usa today came out
uh uh uh talking about which
governorship proposes tax rebate for
california's estate deals with nation's
highest gas prices that's good for him
so he's actually actually wanted to do
something about it good for you uh uh i
think that's a can you can you make that
bigger i want to actually read this on
what he's doing okay they edited the
headline it used to say gavin knew some
comma concerned about midterms comma
proposes tax rebate for california to
see capital government something's going
on yeah make it a little bit bigger than
mcgregor governors knowledge on state
union address tuesday night they came
across californians for the price russia
ukraine invasion ukraine hikes after
okay got it newsom said he is planning
to submit a revised budget to state
legislator that would put money back in
california's pockets to address rising
gas prices but he did not immediately
offer any details of how them okay by
the way if he does this we will give him
credit if he does nationwide the average
gas prices regular gallon reached 417 on
monday breaking a previous record in 20
2008 but in california the average gas
prices are 544 according to aaa that's
crazy that's crazy 544 according to
triple a so
what what's this story with biolabs adam
have you been following this story with
biolabs here's a reuters story russia
says
uss bio labs would plague an anthrax and
ukraine u.s calls claim absurd russia
said on wednesday the united states must
explain that what moscow claims was a
military biological program in ukraine
an allegation washington has already
dismissed as absurd misinformation
russian foreign minister spokesperson
maria
zakharova said evidence of the alleged
program has been uncovered by russia
during what it calls its military
operation in ukraine it involved
deadly pathogens including plague and
anthrax she said zakharova said russia
had documents showing that the ukrainian
health ministry had ordered the
destruction of samples of plague cholera
anthrax and other pathogens after
february 24th
now let me read the next story to you on
biden officials say u.s working with
ukraine to prevent bioresearch
facilities from falling into russian
hands ukrainians biological research
facilities which in fact
we now are quite concerned russia troops
russian forces may be seeking to gain
control of so we are working with the
ukrainians on how we can prevent any of
the research materials from falling into
the hands of russian forces
should they approach okay so that is
being said by under secretary of state
for political affairs victoria new land
okay the response came in regards to a
question from senator marco rubio who
asked does ukraine have chemical or
biological weapons follow newland's
response ruby will continue to ask the
question whether she had any doubt that
they did or not there is no doubt in my
mind senator and it's classic russia
technic to blame on the other guy
what they're planning to do themselves
okay and then some of it links back to
obama but i'll pause right now if you
guys got any thoughts on this go ahead
listen yeah so a couple of things can be
true at the same time i just airdropped
you yeah so this is this this document
that i just airdropped this is from uh
the u.s embassy in ukraine april of 2020
two years ago i found this document and
scroll down a little bit to what this
press release says if you wouldn't mind
yeah so it says the us embassy would
like to set the record straight
regarding disinformation spreading in
some circles in ukraine that mirrors
russian disinformation regarding the
strong u.s ukraine partnership to reduce
biological threats but then listen to
what they say here in ukraine the u.s
department of defense's biological
threat reduction program works with the
ukrainian government to consolidate and
secure pathogens and toxins of security
concern in ukraine government facilities
while allowing for peaceful research and
vaccine development that my friend is
first of all an admission that there are
biological
labs biological weapons labs in ukraine
but this the reason it's so euphemistic
is because once biological weapons
research was sort of banned they still
our government still does this they just
do it under the guise of it being
biodefense and you can tell when there's
a sentence like that they literally say
the us department of defense works with
ukrainian government for peaceful
research like define to me what peaceful
research is because if peaceful research
is the same type of research that the us
was involved in funding and the wuhan
institute of virology then we have we
have a very different definition of of
peaceful here so i think that there is
for almost certain evidence that there
are biological labs in ukraine um that
being said that can be true and it can
also be true that if there is a
biological weapons attack that happens
in ukraine it is almost certainly from
russia those two things can be true at
the same time that's a very good point
i'll read this next story about
president obama deleted web pages show
obama led an effort to build a ukraine
based bio lab handling especially
dangerous pathogens this is a national
paul story two days ago deleted web
article recovered by national policy
revealed that former president barack
obama spearheaded an agreement leading
to construction
of bio labs handling especially
dangerous pathogens in ukraine
originally posted june 18 of 2010 the
article biolab opens in ukraine details
how obama while serving as an illinois
senator helped negotiate a deal to build
a level 3 biosafety lab in ukrainian
city of odessa the article which also
highlighted the work of former senator
dick lugar was additionally included in
issue number 818 the united states air
force uh counter proliferation center
outreach journal so this this so now
i've got a very different question for
you guys very different question for the
two of you so
what is the what is the uh and from the
other side some people are asking this
question what is the big deal with this
meaning
if the enemy in uh uh china the one with
wuhan lab that's very problematic
because you're you're funding the enemy
to come up with certain biowarfare but
if a lot of people the next war is going
to be cyber and it's going to be bio
shouldn't we get smarter in this area
shouldn't we invest some money to
research and get better at this i guess
what i'm asking is why are people being
uh oh no no no we didn't oh no no no we
didn't why are people so worried is
there a guideline that you cannot do
that is there a maybe i'm missing
something is there a criteria that you
cannot do
and and what is that criteria
yeah this is what happens when
when well when liberals in charge of our
country make decisions about what
research is allowed or not based on what
the international community thinks
versus what's in our best interest
there's certainly an argument that could
be made that says well it's in our best
interest to have bio weapons right like
i think that's a perfectly valid
argument i probably would agree with
that but because it's against because
it's against the law right now because
you know the gain of function research
is against the law this juicing up of
viruses or toxins to make them more
transmissible and more lethal to
weaponize them because this is against
the law it's really shocking when people
hear that the government is violating
the law for their own interest i mean
that that was the problem with fouchy
right this is actually this is actually
why i think fauci has disappeared from
the airwaves because what's happening in
ukraine is just another example of
fauci pretending that he's not engaging
in bioweapons
research he's just doing it under the
guise of biodefense because remember the
the nih and the nia id which is the sub
agency that fauci's in charge of at the
nih they
control i'm not joking literally
billions of dollars as it pertains to
bio defense spending so any any bio
defense funding in our country fauci's
finger is in this and this is this is i
mean it's a scandal great great point by
the way i don't like that we're doing it
in ukraine i don't like it that we're
doing it in china i don't like it that
that's being done and this that you just
post up right here tyler uh the
biological weapon convention bwc is a
legally binding treaty that outlaws
biological arms after being discussed
and negotiated in the united nations
disarmament form starting in 1969 the
bwc opened for signature on april 10
1972 and entered into force a martial
next ignition that's 183 state uh
parties including palestine and four
signatories egypt haiti somalia syria
tanzania 10 states that have neither
signed nor ratified the bwc chat
none of those are big states south sudan
okay in terms of bwc okay so so this
says you can't do it
but now how much has it changed since
then who's holding up to this who's
committing to this and quite frankly do
you know when people say does iran have
a nuclear weapon you know that whole
conversation about this you don't have a
nuclear weapon i asked the question how
can you really audit whether they do or
not like let's just ask that question
how can you do it iran's not a small
country how do you go figure out whether
they have it or not you don't think they
have some creative places to be able to
have a nuclear weapon you don't think
they're currently working on it you
think they do it in a structure with
glass windows for people from the
outside like you know how you go to new
york and you know look at cnn studio or
fox and it's glass you can see somebody
doing the show you think they work on
weapons like that with glass windows for
audiences oh awesome look at this we
have a nuclear bomb being built you guys
are so awesome can i take a picture of
my kids here's a selfie
so if they're doing it do we not think
america is doing it
quite frankly i don't know if i would be
comfortable with this and here's why let
me tell you why i wouldn't be
comfortable with this and it kind of
goes to the second amendment with me
your pro second amendment yeah okay i am
too right uh this essentially is a form
of a second amendment argument here's
why
sammy the bull garvano said something
very interesting to me sami double
garvano he's a former gangster he's you
know
being accused of no he actually went for
19 19 murders right that are linked to
him he said the following to me about
second amendment he says listen
me as a gangster
go ahead and ban all guns
go ahead and ban all weapons guess what
i'm gonna get guns
i'm gonna find a way to have a gun go
ahead and do your
background checks and all the stuff you
want to do i promise you i'm gonna have
a gun right okay
um
can we agree that there's a lot of
countries worldwide that can't stand
america
that if we apply the same concept right
here
with second amendment do you not think
the bad guys are saying oh yeah yeah
yeah let's ban biological
you know labs and research yeah yeah
let's do it you're right wink we're
gonna follow your guidelines check check
and then they're gonna go and say what
the hell are these naive people doing
behind closed doors everybody's working
on this because what happened the last
two years to the world
was that not a you know a
not not putting a link to china or
whoever was that not a biological crisis
whoever it was so we have to still do
the investigation was that not a
biological crisis that it spread and
stop the entire world so for me
with ukraine of course not with china
absolutely not
but do i kind of want my military to get
stronger and invest into studying these
types of things that could potentially
take our lives and half the population
can be lost and we're not prepared for
it and we're going to say oh we were
following the rules no the other guy
wasn't following the rules and we need
to renegotiate this still asap because
we're not going to sit here like a bunch
of naive you know god-fearing people oh
everything's going to work out no only
the paranoid survive cyber warfare is
going to make people's life a hell we
already experienced what happened with
bayou i don't know i i'm going a
completely different direction i may be
fully wronged no i no you're absolutely
right you're absolutely right and if you
go take a look at um arms reductions
treaties and you can go back to carter
and reagan on this salt and salt 2.
strategic arms limitation talks it's the
same bumper sticker that the nra uses
and it's right if guns are outlawed only
outlaws have guns it's the same thing if
you make a treaty like this and by the
way it was found out in the transition
between gorbachev and trinico right you
remember this trench was a complete
drunk
um true
and they weren't concerned about his his
finger on their form of the nuclear
football that the president carries
around they were concerned about
deterioration of the russian nuclear
missiles that were happening in silos
because they were poorly built
and that's where it was and so basically
what you have is the bad guys will
continue to work against the good guys
pat you're absolutely right and it's not
about second amendment it's that no
treaty made with russia on salt or salt
2 was not violated by the russians it is
a historical fact they opened up silos
they looked at them and the whole ussr
you know fell became russia they're able
to look at this they're like that thing
is deteriorating in there that thing can
go off right here you can destroy one
third of this little surrounding area
this way and then chernobyl reactor was
one example of it
we have to be doing research but
unfortunately the good guys end up
having to do it by proxy
you have to go and have labs because the
good guys that do
have glass buildings
well that's also the problem though
right and the proxies are dangerous
people like the chinese communists or
the ukrainians i mean say what you will
about the resistance the courage of the
ukrainian people right now that's fine
but ukraine is a corrupt nation they're
they're not a functional democracy they
they are not someone that we should be
sharing in my opinion bioweapons
information with there's also i i know i
keep coming back to the corruption but
there there's a corruption that can't be
ignored too when the same person who is
giving money
to you know when not to be vague here
when fauci gives money to eco health
alliance and they give money to the
wuhan institute of virology to do this
exact gain of function research when
that same agency that fauci helms
profits from a vaccine that supposedly
supposedly
addresses this virus like that's a
that's a level of corruption and and
vulnerability for profit off of you know
mass death that i don't think the
american people want to ignore no and by
the way what i'm for is let's
investigate you know i'm for innocent
until proven guilty jesse smallett you
know uh everybody was saying who he was
i don't know if you see what's going on
with him right now he's trying to get
back onto tv and acting and all this
other stuff but everybody jumped to
conclusions saying oh my gosh it's you
know trump's campaign innocent until
proven guilty we should if that happened
to the guy freaking terrible that's a
terrible situation and we find out no
that was all a fluke did you see uh did
you want to say something well i was
just going to say we kind of glossed
over the incompetence here that the the
biden administration has had over a year
to prepare for a russian invasion of
ukraine russia started moving troops to
the border in what march of 2021 if not
earlier and we're just now worrying
about the level three bio lab and to
evacuate it and get the deadly pathogens
out of it are you kidding me like what
what are these people doing this is
incompetence of the highest level these
things should have been handled a year
ago and it should when the question came
up in the congressional hearing victoria
newlands should have said yes it's been
taken care of we handled it six months
ago seven months ago what is that one
scene in godfather where they try to
kill marlon brando
uh do you know that one scene where they
had to come and
retaliate because you can't show
weakness do you know what i'm talking
about
the scene right okay
so
everybody's watching
to see
how you handle
somebody going after your number one guy
and they went after biden
taliban did and they got what they want
and everybody said
well marlon brando and his camp didn't
do anything
well when they after went after trump
and they came after us rasam soleimani
the number two guy was gone
so iran's like let's shoot an empty
place and act like we retaliated they
didn't do nothing
why
okay so in sports one of the things that
kobe when we had a mom kobe said i said
kobe you know if shaq had to work i
think who would have been who would he
have been he says what he would have
been the mo the greatest basketball
player of all time the greatest of all
time
i said why he says because he was
vicious he was physical most big guys
are not intimidating but he didn't care
he would push you he would hit you he
would do all this stuff right okay
so shaq
trump they had a reputation of what
you do this i'm retaliating you're gonna
hear from me right
so imagine all of a sudden you try to
teach a center like roy hibbert hey i
want you to be a tough guy because look
dude i've never been a tough guy i'm
just tall what do you want me to do i'm
7-2 don't blame me for being 7-2 i'm
just not a tough guy
okay i'm gonna beat you but don't do it
roy relax bro chill out you're a nice
guy you're not a bad guy right
biden doesn't know how to do that so
these guys are exploiting that
opportunity of not seeing tough it's
very simple
and the enemy is capitalizing off this
opportunity fyi this story just came in
if you want to show it on what just
happened
ukraine and the russia foreign minister
met together i don't know if you guys
saw that video
uh they had talks together nothing there
is no peace treaty nothing came out of
it ukraine four minutes it says russian
officials
live in their own reality after talks
fail if you want to go up so i can read
this talks between russian ukraine
foreign minister and turkey on thursday
ended in failure the discussions between
larov and kuleba lasted just an hour to
have ukraine foreign minister
uh comments uh come after russia's
foreign minister earlier denied that
russian forces had targeted civilians by
bombing a children's hospital and
maternity uh award on wednesday so
here's a good here's a bat what's the
good at least they faced off and they
had a meeting which is good okay
there is some progress going on okay
just the fact that they're willing to do
that i feel it's progress negotiations
sometimes you don't get it done the
first time or the second time around but
they were able to get together
does this mean it's over and putin's
going to say okay guys let's just kind
of don't worry about it it's okay i'm
over it that's we know that's not the
kind of guy he is he's going to continue
but uh
i don't know i don't know what with all
the stuff that's going on right now at
what level are we going to see this
slowing down all i know is i'm a little
bit more hopeful than i was two days ago
with the fact that these guys had to sit
down what do you think yeah there's a
really interesting article that is out
on the federalists about war games there
are over a hundred times in the last 10
years there have been simulations of
what happens when russia invades ukraine
does this draw in the united states does
this draw in nato does this result in
nuclear war and this guy was a part of
it he was a part of these war games and
he said every single time it resulted in
nuclear war because when putin feels
boxed in when he feels that his country
or himself when he if he feels mortally
threatened he unleashes a nuclear weapon
and this this article to me was really
eye-opening i actually like pondered it
it was in my mind for like two or three
days because i had been a little more on
the while zolensky is really courageous
he's staying there he's staying in his
office the people are being like the
resistance is amazing the propaganda i
forgive him for because that's that's
just that's the new kind of war right
and it made me actually rethink my view
on
zelensky's strategy and how it's
agitating the world and the reason i use
the word agitating is because i had used
the word rowling he's rallying the world
behind you know behind his cause on
behalf of the ukrainian people against
putin who's obviously evil and doing a
bad thing and i after i read this
article i thought actually what he's
doing is he's agitating the world
because and the reason for that is
because he wants people meaning voters
us america specifically and europe he
wants the people to have an emotional
connection to the ukrainian people so
that we pressure our lawmakers to give
him what he needs but if you read this
federalist piece and it it it talks
about what specifically tips putin over
the edge to a nuclear war you know just
the slightest like a no-fly zone tips
putin over into a nuclear war um certain
weapons tip putin over into a nuclear
war because he doesn't want to be struck
first and it made me think the united
states should be very very careful we
obviously should condemn putin of course
he's evil and he shouldn't be doing what
he's doing but we should be very very
cautious and very skeptical of what
zelensky the operation that he is waging
against us or trying to get our approval
because things as simple as
words
or those jeffs
yeah offends putin to the point that he
feels mortally threatened and i was very
encouraged i actually think zolensky
should consider the deal that the
kremlin offered him they offered him
they said you know acknowledge that
crimea is russian and acknowledge that
these separatist regions are independent
and um put in your constitution that you
won't you won't get into nato or the eu
and you know this will he the words from
the kremlin word this will all stop in a
minute if i were zolensky i'd seriously
consider that well it sounds like he is
i think he had a couple comments that
that basically he's not
interested in joining nato what's the
quote that he said yeah that was that
was just yesterday i think exactly was
cooled
he's cooled on that and and they're that
they're open to those regions you know
from russian-backed separatists
rejoining the russian federation what
have you
um
but
you gotta hand it to the guy man i mean
the world is rallying around this guy
and and i think it's only going to get
worse for the russian economy i think
they're going to default on uh on their
loans what's that story if you want to
cover that morgan stanley well just just
real quick uh we got a pretty good
interesting comment in here and a lot of
people echo this it's from a guy named
critic geek and adam it's all officially
your fault
i just wanted to let you know it's all
adam's
why does tyler have a mic sometimes
makes a lot of sense i mean it does
point back to one person it's not adam
but it points back to biden i mean this
could all have been avoided none of this
had happened that's why i that's why i
recommend to zolensky that he consider
this it's not because it's a good deal
it's not no one wants to give up part of
their self-determination their autonomy
or their democracy but it's because
we're in this lose-lose situation the
binary options both are terrible
the reason we're in that binary choice
is because of decisions made by joe
biden
what should bide have done differently
he should have in regards to this he
should have continued the sanctions on
the nordstrom 2 pipeline that's probably
the single thing that could have
prevented this the most he also also
should have
he not been relying on russian oil he
should have continued our the united
states path towards energy independence
um those two things i mean that's really
the leverage that putin has those two
things putin cares about his profit he
cares about his pocketbook just like
everybody does and if you threaten that
that's also that's also his leverage for
controlling the response from european
nations so biden really just could have
done those those two or three things and
this could have been prevented
so the morgan stanley story we're
talking about is a fortune story says
russia could default as soon as next
month morgan stanley says russia's
economy is so weak that it may have to
default on its foreign debt soon with
analysts comparing it to venezuela in a
note on monday
simon waiver morgan stanley's global
head of emergency market sovereign
credit strategy warned that russia's
economy was inching
perilously
close to default territory as the west
imposes sanctions and talks of a
recession mount we see a default as most
likely scenario waiver said predicting
that the default may occur on as early
as april 15 a date that will mark the
end of 30-day grace period on coupon
payments that the russian government
owes on dollar bonds in case of default
it is unlikely to be a normal one with
venezuela instead perhaps the most
relevant comparison
what does the default do to russia i
mean he just the guy the guy's making a
threat saying i'll take it to 300. uh
instead of uh what it is today you want
to do a default with us they're just
going to make 40 of you still relying on
these guys with gas do you really think
this default is real threat to russia
no i don't think so either no the
sanctions go one way not i'm not going
to pay you next month that it doesn't
work it doesn't work that way you know i
read a very interesting book called you
know the next czar um and it's a story
about putin and it's very very
interesting when you read about it you
read about where he went up and where
his education was and and one of the
things is
he is employing czar thinking and part
of the tsar thinking is you know
military imperialism and rebuild and
rebuilding but the other part of bizarre
thinking is zero endgame
i mean the tsars were literally
unafraid of
you know
of of their own mortality or fatality
and and that is the character flaw that
was in the czars and so when i read this
and what you talk about but you're just
talking about just now liz i mean it
lines up you know beware the guy that
really isn't concerned about the end
game the way you think of an end game
yeah but at what point does putin like
we're saying that it's biden's fault
okay maybe there's parts of it that it
is but at what point does putin have to
accept responsibility that attacking
ukraine and invading ukraine is
basically crumbling
and dismantling the russian economy what
uh inflation has reached double digits
by far interest rates are 20 percent at
this point the ruble is crumbling is
worth a penny you can't use your
mastercard atm i'm our visa
amex
the stores are closing their sanctions
galore i mean at the end of the day is
it all worth it so you can take back
parts of russia that are you know
russian-backed uh and speak russian at
what point does putin have to say you
know what
this isn't actually a good idea to do
all this you're applying western thought
of good bad that's not how he's thinking
i'm sorry i i mean is western is your
economy crumbling and your and your
ruble crumbling a western philosophy he
i don't think he's worried about it how
can you not well if you're not if you're
not accountable to your people i mean
right that's the problem with dictators
and authoritarian is when things are
going badly for the people that people
don't have the power to say well we're
going to vote you out of office we're
going to hold you accountable when
someone's an author authoritarian
they're going to live high on the hog
and it doesn't really matter if the
people suffer i actually had a really
interesting conversation with senator
ted cruz i co-host that new series the
cloak room with him on verdict plus and
i asked him about putin's mental state
because there's been some insinuations
from people like senator marco rubio or
even condoleezza rice she was on the
view and she said listen i i interacted
with putin five or six times in person
and he's a killer he's evil but he's a
rational actor as defined in foreign
policy meaning not a jihadist not a
death wish she's a rational actor but
she said recently his behavior seems to
be more erratic it doesn't seem to be in
that same vein and so i this
obviously they didn't go into this much
deeper on the view and i thought wow we
really should be talking about that
exact comment and so i asked senator
cruz i was like listen i have access to
a lot of open source information you
have access to a lot of classified
information what's the what's the
psychoanalysis of vladimir putin is he
still acting as a rational actor and i
mean obviously he can't he can't
disclose super classified information
but he said as far as he can tell as far
as he's seen putin is still acting as a
rational actor if you understand what
his ideology is which should inform the
world it should inform the world what
are how we react and these sanctions i
mean these sanctions
understand who they hurt the most too
they hurt not just the people they heard
the oligarchs and the oligarchs there
control putin they're very influential
so you're saying that they control putin
yeah yeah the oligarchy needs the
support of the oligarchs but then that
goes to your point though what you said
yesterday
that meaning you what does he listen to
yeah so you can't lose them if they lose
their minds you saw what happened with
the soccer thing the other day yesterday
the
britain roman chelsea romana abramovic
baby the owner of the nets too had to
sell the nets and the barclays arena uh
he was a russian because he had tied to
vladimir putin yeah he sold that five
years ago that wasn't recently that was
years ago but now i mean think about
what's happening to them right now i
mean their yachts their yachts are being
sunk they can't go to the riviera they
can't send their children to elite
universities around the globe i mean
they
yeah roman obama that started to cut you
off was actually sanctioned this morning
and now he can't sell the club for the 3
billion pounds he wanted to sell it for
so my point initially was i hope it's
all worth it vladimir yeah i hope all
this is worth getting crimea
that
you know you're losing support in your
country you're losing support from the
oligarchs your people are standing in
bread lines atm lines the ruble's worth
nothing but hey
you got a little more territory i think
i think the whole thing the strategy is
what outwork out improve out strategize
but what's the last one outlast this is
a lasting game right now this is all a
stamina and fatigue game right now now
do you think this actually helps him
out last or does this diminish his
chances of outlining no i think if
kremlin is making the request on what
they want i think
he is waiting for zielinski to burn out
and fatigue and say okay fine we'll make
it work look what happened with
pashinian from armenia eventually he
says okay let's get down let's sit down
and talk and they sat down with
azerbaijan and putin and figured out a
way to do it right that happened very
quickly not very quickly it was about a
month no i mean it didn't take months
and months and months and months no no
no
an award for a month but but you're
telling us we've still got a couple
weeks left till april 15 default so this
guy has a timeline in his mind he's
thinking i'm gonna go till this day like
this is not a meeting it's like what do
they say go this is a meeting of
40 moves ahead of what we're gonna if
this guy says this this is the plan if
that guy says this this is the plan if
that guy says start this press this send
this guy to call send this call the
media on this shut this thing down of me
they this is this is a
months and months maybe a year's
strategy of what to do in this moment
that's all it is i don't think they're
winning a default is basically when you
just don't make your payments right i
think
i think he has a time in his head does
do you think that's my question do you
think he's actually concerned about this
april 15th deadline i don't think it's
ironically a saturday i'm just given the
date that morgan stanley gives i just
think he has a date on the default date
i'm saying is do you think he's
concerned about no he's he don't that's
not that if they go back to communism
the people in that country is like what
are you talking about just 30 years ago
to comedy and what you guys complaining
about yeah but but i'm saying this that
he's thinking this i'm not saying it as
i'm saying it that's how he processes
that you know what international women's
day he said
hey on international women's day this is
a great opportunity for us to recognize
our men that are at war
this is his mentality
this is the international woman's day
appreciate our men in the fight
we got five more minutes i want to do
two other stories before we wrap up one
is with jeff zucker cnn page 10 if you
want to go to it uh uh jeff zucker okay
reaches resolution with warner media
over abrupt cnn exit won't sue jeff
sucker has finalized the deal with
warner media over the former cnn chief
sudden fall of his grace last month
details of confidential package are
obviously being kept close to the vest
but sources tell us zucker made the
decision several weeks ago to accept
what had been done on the table by the
old bosses at the time of the table news
exit what we know is that if warner
media kept
keeps its side of the deal in the next
two weeks ten days in the next two weeks
to 10 days in the next week to 10 days
zachel will receive a one-time payment
of 10 million dollars we altered zucker
quite
publicly since his departure cnn seized
his chance as a move on and pursued the
next chapter of his career in terms of
moving on as part of his agreement with
warner media the one-time nbc universal
head honcho has waived any future rights
or intention to pursue litigation
against his old corporate overlords
which is very normal when you do that
this is not like anything crazy but the
story that is crazy is what james
o'keefe did
he did this james o'keefe got man he is
relentless a pulitzer prize winning new
york times reporter says
january 6 media coverage overreaction
fbi involved even
event was not organized despite ongoing
uh
narrative so go to page six on this one
because
uh
he's not slowing down so new york times
national security correspondent matthew
rosenberg contradicts his own january 6
reporting there were a ton of fbi
informants amongst the people who
attacked the capitol let me say this one
more time by the way he's on video
saying this talking to a girl i'm sure
you guys saw this and then yesterday
o'keefe was following him with a mic in
his face and he's saying turn the camera
off he says this is an america this is
free speech it'll keeps
on a different level rosenberg it was
like me and two other colleagues who
were there on january 6 outside and we
were just having fun i know i'm supposed
to be traumatized but like all these
colleagues who were in the capitol
building and are like oh my god it was
so scary i'm like you know f off
rosenberg i'm like come on it's not the
kind of place i can tell someone to man
up but i kind of wanted to be like dude
come on you were not in any danger
these little dweebs who keep doing uh on
about their trauma shut the hell up the
their effing uh [ __ ] okay rosenberg
they were making too big of a deal they
were making the this an organized crime
that it wasn't so
zucker cnn new york times called out how
much trust how much more trust are we
having in the media today and they keep
losing credibility
the article about zucker cracks me up
because it says you know he's going to
keep the details of the settlement close
to his chest and then the rest of the
article is all the details and fyi i
mean i don't have to tell you guys this
anytime it says a source close to zucker
like that's zucker on his phone like
typing out what he wants them to print
that is not that is not anybody close to
him he's he's publishing what he wants
to print listen he was fired not because
of the affair that he had with that
woman which i think we all agree no one
cares about um he's an adult it was
consensual he can he can do that if he
wants i mean makes him a pig but that's
not really a fireable offense um the
reason he was fired obviously was
because he helped cover up andrew cuomo
and chris cuomo helped cover up andrew
cuomo's malfeasance even andrew cuomo's
sexual malfeasance like that's bad don't
get me wrong but he wasn't ousted
because of that he was ousted because he
was going to be held accountable for the
nursing home deaths that he facilitated
during covent so this is just this is
just the domino effect um the domino
effect is jeff zucker helped help chris
cuomo who helped andrew cuomo who
presided over the deaths of thousands of
old people in new york he deserves to be
fired for that i mean he's taken cnn i
think it's what the joe rogan podcast
has like 11 times more viewers every day
than prime time cnn that if you stop and
think about that statistic for a second
i mean he has presided over the just the
devastation of uh of cnn which you know
is sad to see in one sense but also i i
find to be quite humorous given how
biased they are well don't you think
that that might be a partial reason is
that their ratings are in the tank and
by the way all networks are getting
killed by joe rogan i don't think it's
immune to cnn i mean no electronics
don't have an x no wonder if the animals
don't want math
how much of it is just because he tied
all his ratings to trump they would they
would have cameras on the podium when
trump wasn't even there like he's coming
like he was been there for the last 10
years before uh he was there for obama
for trump how much of it is actually the
sexual accusations cover-ups versus dude
like
cnn's failing no that's what i'm saying
i don't think it's about his his affair
or whatever i don't i honestly don't
think people really care about that
outside of his personal life i don't
mean to sound i don't think it was an
affair he was just banging a co-worker
who happened to be 45 years old it
wasn't like she was some intern you know
roger
i really i literally don't even care
about the affair he was obviously fired
because not i don't even think it was
because cnn's ratings are in the tank i
think it's because of the andrew cuomo
stuff i mean cnn lost their credibility
not not necessarily just because they
had a camera on the podium for trump but
because of how they covered trump cnn
literally had remember remember the
kavanaugh hearings cnn brian stelter had
on michael avenatti and said you are a
realistic 2020 um presidential campaign
like
mine who's literally in jail right now
yeah who who who stole money from a porn
star yeah based on the book that she
wrote i mean this guy is nuts and brian
stelter and other clients yeah and brian
stelter's pushing her only because she's
making allegations or the allegations
against kavanaugh and against trump so
who's the alpha at cnn now is it brian
stelter is it don lemon is it it's
definitely not three two one
as they get have those two words
in the same sentence
brian is brian should go sit down with
you and uh uh
rollo that's because he would be the
ultimate beta he's coming up on the
south carolina liz i think you're
absolutely right i think there's nothing
to see here on zucker zucker has agreed
to two thoughts in his mind
10 million is good
to shut up and get my career ready for
my next chapter in media maybe i don't
sue the world including boards of
directors you know what i want to work
in media time to shut up sign the paper
get on with it and have my quiet period
and then come back and get re-involved
which is what he's going to do yeah
that's what's going on here he's not
going away he's not going away but i
think you're right i think liz is
absolutely correct the derivative of
liability that was coming to cnn look
cnn also yesterday the new chief what
did he announce we've agreed to a
cease-fire with fox so while we're all
covering wars is that you did you see
that they used the phrase ceasefire
we're not going to be all over fox for
this they're not going to be over this
we're going to go more to hard reporting
stories and so cnn is also trying to go
good and say hey we're going to be a
journalist we're going to be doing this
all this is interrelated but jeff sucker
is easy jeff take the money
don't sue anybody do your time out and
quiet
then come back and do whatever you want
to seal the company look a couple couple
things i i watch two documentaries that
i recommend people to watch one of
them's gonna piss off one audience the
other one's gonna piss off another
audience one of them was a a
winter on fire and a ukraine on fire
ukraine on fire i believe is by uh
oliver stone and winter on fire is on
sean penn i am curious to know how putin
thinks and oliver stone sits
with putin like i'd love to have a
conversation with oliver stone to see
what he thinks
about putin you know like how was this
guy's wiring when you had to sit down
with them what was it like so oliver
stone does that interview then sean penn
does the other one with the students and
the kids all that other stuff if you
haven't watched it can we can you show
both of those documentaries so people
can see it listen
next 24 48 hours do one of them then
watch the other one i think one of them
is on netflix and the other one you can
watch on imdb that's a ukraine one from
2016. okay
uh and then go to the other one uh that
explains winter on fire and that's on
netflix i want to say right there's
those two i recommend you watching those
and then more importantly
if you were not subscribed to liz
wheeler's podcast we're going to put the
link below
if you loved having around go give her a
sub
and give her a shout out of her being
here on the podcast with us liz you're
amazing you're exactly what we expected
you to be fiery energetic and somebody
that puts a lot of time into researching
to give the answers where you get people
thinking appreciate you so much for
coming i really enjoyed having you on
thank you so much for the kind words it
was uh my honor to be here with you
gentlemen awesome so gang tomorrow one
of the podcasts will only be on spotify
we can't do it live because youtube
guidelines won't allow an apple podcast
spotify an apple patch spotify apple
podcast and the other one will be on
youtube
and uh just you don't want to miss the
other one let's just say the afternoon
one will be very interesting that's
probably a very good way of putting it
so all right so we'll see you guys
tomorrow take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you